nations is warning the
israeli-palestinian conflict could turn
into an all-out war already dozens have
been killed
by rockets and a ground invasion could
be next president biden says
israel has a right to defend itself even
as the biden administration hopes for
a de-escalation of tension
we strongly condemn the rocket attacks
coming out of gaza that are targeting
innocent israeli civilians and israel
has a right to defend itself
palestinians have a right to live in
safety
and security secretary of state there
foreign correspondent trey yangste in
the region
from the beginning joins us live with
the latest developments good evening
brett good evening breaking tonight air
raid sirens just minutes ago sounded in
central and northern israel
as hamas says they are now firing once
again long-range rockets
towards the jewish state we know today
the death toll in gaza rose to almost 60
people in
israel one soldier died and also a
six-year-old boy
this is a major escalation by the
factions inside gaza
as behind me tonight in the gaza strip
we have heard loud explosions
the israeli air force targeting a number
of high-rise buildings
a red line for hamas and islamic jihad
the factions inside gaza
who are now not only firing on israel
from the air but also the ground earlier
today
we know that hamas used an anti-tank
unit to fire
on a group of israeli soldiers that were
sitting inside of a jeep
all of the soldiers severely injured and
one of them did die
at the hospital we spoke with the doctor
that treated them saying that he
believes hamas is getting more advanced
weaponry
inside gaza those high-rise buildings
were really the major focus of
conversation for the factions there that
we spoke with today
who said in the coming hours things
would continue to escalate
some of the missiles did slip past the
missile defense system the iron dome
today
as we noted killing that six-year-old in
the town of sterot
also we visited a site in the city of
ashkelon where a rocket
slammed into a building people came out
bloodied
looking for their loved ones this is the
scene unfolding here in israel
again as air raid sirens are going off
tonight brett
trey yanks on the ground we'll head back
for any breaking details trey thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else